tischtennis spielen oder billard danach
ins fitnessstudio und anschließend im
café bevor es wieder an die arbeit geht
um gute leute zu halten lassen sich die
firmen so einiges einfallen
vor allem kreativ unternehmen die auf
die ideen ihrer mitarbeiter angewiesen
sind müssen auch ein inspirierendes
umfeld bieten viele startup arbeiten in
gemeinschaftsbüros wie er einem loft
ähneln
ich frage mich was macht menschen im
büro kreativ welche umgebung motiviert
sie am fraunhofer-institut treffe ich
wissenschaftler die dazu studien gemacht
haben
man muss raus können muss ein neues
neues sehen aber auch auf neue menschen
treffen bis wir haben gleich aussehen
das wird relativ wenig so mit 10 15
prozent abwesenheit vom arbeitsplatz
also dass da tatsächlich die ideen
ansteigen die dann wieder mit
zurückbringen
die büros am institut ist sind so
gestaltet dass dies laut
forschungsergebnissen idealen die
einzelnen etagen sind die beiden offene
treppenhaus verbunden
das soll für mehr kommunikation sorgen
aber wer konzentriert arbeiten will der
kann sich auch zurückziehen
raumteiler sollen den schalldämpfer
es gibt keine festen arbeitsplätze
jeder sucht sich jeden tag einen neuen
ort viel abwechslung ist also wichtig
und die büroumgebung sollte sich meinen
bedürfnissen anpassen
und die haben eigentlich ihre für
unternehmen die ihre büros nach
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
einrichten wollen wurde eine 3d software
entwickelt mit der sich räume virtuell
begehen lassen
gute idee so kann man schon vorher
testen ob man sich wohlfühlt microsoft
hat zum beispiel seine
deutschlandzentrale zusammen mit dem
fraunhofer-institut gestaltet auch die
wirkung von licht wird erforscht
in diesem besprechungsraum letztlich
tageslicht simulieren inklusive
sonnenuntergang die arbeitswelt
verändert sich das haben auch große
konzerne erkannt wie der
sportartikelhersteller puma das
durchschnittsalter der mitarbeiter liegt
hier bei 33 jahren junge leute aus aller
welt kommen nach herzogenaurach in die
deutsche provinz auch wegen der lockeren
arbeitsatmosphäre
die neuen büros wurden in zusammenarbeit
mit designern gestaltet die schlichten
räume sollen ein kreatives arbeiten
unterstützen
mitarbeiter können wählen ob sie immer
am gleichen schreibtisch setzen oder
lieber flexibel arbeiten wollen der
personalchef hat die mitarbeiter befragt
wie sie das offene büro finden denn auf
einzelbüros müssen sie verzichten
im prinzip geht es um zwei dinge
meistens es geht um clique
umgebungsgeräusche und wenn wir diese
maßnahmen insofern dann auch umsetzen
und umsetzte hier kriegt man eigentlich
sehr positiven zuspruch was jetzt an
openoffice konzept angeht
dazu gehört auch der tischkicker in der
mittagspause das haben sich die großen
firmen bei dem start abgebrochen
die schallschutz kabine
sie will ich selbst gästen als viel
telefonieren und dann habe ich mir eine
pause verdient
insgesamt einfach mehr freiräume das
scheint das wichtigste zu sein
im neuen wohlfühl büro